okay so I guess I should explain what's
going on especially if this ends up
going on YouTube
so first of all for people watching in
the future on YouTube this is Roxy she
might be joining for a good portion of
the Stream
but about what was it about a week ago
maybe five or six days ago I did a
collaboration with Anna crowling and a
bunch of other chess streamers uh
bowtest sisters Nemo Alessia
and
um we played this game called Arctic
phone
and it wasn't really supposed to be a
competitive game it's like a drawing
game kind of like Pictionary meets
telephone
and I really struggled with it
um
we gave each other prompts to draw and
uh it was a big struggle for me but
anyway we played like a competitive
version with points
and I failed to draw accurate pictures I
also failed to like guess what other
people drew
so as a result I didn't get enough
points and we had some wager that the
higher scoring players
would get to choose the profile picture
on chess.com of the lower scoring player
so it turns out that Anna crowling got
to choose my new profile picture
on chess.com
and of course she
sent me this image to replace what used
to be my beautiful face
and because my profile picture is now a
cow I feel obligated to play the cow
opening I guess I'm going all all in
I'll be playing the cow opening in every
single game today in title choose a
regardless of my opponent whether it's
like a FM or if it's Hikaru uh
it'll be embarrassing if I end up
playing one of the the higher rated GMS
okay Roxy doesn't want to witness this
um but for those that don't know the cow
opening I posted a video on YouTube
earlier today featuring one game I
played the cattle but it's basically an
opening where
first of all it's an opening that Anna
kramling I think just invented uh where
you play E3 D3
bring the knights to B3 and G3 and then
put the Bishops on D2 and E2
so it's a purely system based opening
which means I can play it as white and
as black
now of course uh the opponent might try
and disturb
my beautiful cow and if that's the case
then
I'll have to adjust hey it's Angus
Carlson
the the goats
the goat of all cows
well if I get to play the cow against
Magnus finally I am home when you are
streaming I mean if you think about it
cows are probably more powerful than
goats
right
I think I would be pretty bullish on
that that fact
has Magnus ever encountered the cow
opening
I don't think he really plays people
that are capable of playing the cow
moo moo okay
yeah I have to be careful not to have
like muscle memory take over
so the cool thing is I could pre-move
here
and
wait opponent's playing the hippo
it's a cow versus the hippo
uh do I play this move I guess
okay cow opening completed now I can
focus on
trying to fix my position
[Music]
also construction just started outside
my door I'm gonna
uh
I'm gonna be right back
uh am I already losing a pawn it might
be
H4 is actually kind of weak
all right let's play
man
let's play this
this is such a bad position
I want my nylon F3 where it belongs
okay I have some idea of uh Bishop G5
let's start with I have F4 as well
one's ready to queenside Castle let's
start with Bishop G5
ideas to get the Knight to C4
like I'm down the pond but it's it's not
so bad
I have this move
I'm literally undoing the cow of this
first game
my night not had no purpose there I mean
black played well to restrict it
but I'm finding a new purpose in life
up on time which is nice
yeah if anything hopefully I can milk my
time advantage
F6 is maybe coming
I'm literally undoing all the moves
Bishop H3 is the move I want to play
visual H3 will continue to harass a
queen
and I still have casting rights on the
queen side which is nice
if Queen G4 I trap the queen
start with this
and B5 is slightly annoying I sack and
queen F4 in some cases
depends where the queen goes
if F6 I triple Fork
that would be sweet
like ice cream
yeah I have to turn it into milk and
then turn it into ice cream
what to do though a four
yeah might as well The Rook is actually
well placed on a file
if B4 I bring the Knight back to C4
yeah I don't mind opening things up
in this move now
a cow is turning into a giga cow
look at my Rook Bishop's pinned
I'm up almost a minute now
Queen's ready to come in too
still trying to calculate things
the opponent's Frozen
yeah King B they played this move
Queen A6 is now an idea
I have Knight takes F7 doesn't quite
work maybe
take take
hmm
I can take everything
how to do this
I think we trade everything
oh
I was not expecting Knight takes
I think it's still okay
I messed up
ah
check there
how do I save the Knight
have to play this
wait I have this move now
um
foreign
let's go
there we go let's go okay
oh almost let that one slip
okay back over 2600 undefeated so far
not the prettiest of games but
okay I'm not I'm not going zero out of
11.
it's a success
okay I'm playing
I'm playing Mont lock of
like we've played serious games against
each other in the past but
is he prepared for the cow
yeah already playing
man my G6 is such a sad move to play
as H4 move
oh this feels so wrong to do I can't
complete my development or maybe now I
can
always play F6
okay this cow is has had a rough
upbringing but
it's entering entering the middle game
not the worst thing ever at least I'm
not down material
maybe F5 at some point
yeah that's a good move
take take take
and take first and then play F5
so actually one material there
but white has positional compensation
[Music]
this move
before comes
in this move no
and this is really the best I could ask
for
yeah casting green side still doesn't
look that great but
especially now
A6
I think I'm trying to Nah by Queen side
Castle there there
I feel so wrong but
I want to play this and
so I have this in Knight C5
B file opens though
if I play F5 first
doesn't really do much
so the idea is still playing Knight C5
maybe even
like B6
hmm
I really want to play F5
trade Queens
uh E4 is no longer hanging
take Taking V8
play this move
probably not
trying to stay alive here
foreign
[Music]
has two passers
you know what I want
what I really really want
foreign
okay
I survived a long time
made it to the end game the cow lived a
good life
what to do I wonder if I ever had any
chances that game game review
oh no my cow
okay there's probably not gonna be a
long break
78 accuracy
white was always better at hacking
but there is a point where I was only
only 1.8 ish
life goes on only a point behind Magnus
now
thank you Onyx a dog okay new game we'll
start with D3 this time
remove D3 Knight yeah
Knight D2 try and at least get the
opening played quickly
and play A4 I learned my lesson from the
past
okay cow opening achieved
maybe I'll play C3 and queen C2
it's one way to
develop
and then probably go for E4
yeah this actually isn't so bad
the component didn't really
try and punish me so much
I could play C4
there's an idea to play C4 D4 C5
Center my close down
yeah again the knight's restricted like
it's an issue with the cow at pawns on
B6 and G6
I have to live with it
maybe this move
if I play Maybe C5 first
positional sacrifice
to open up the bishop
I have to let the cow roam free
yeah this is interesting because I I'm
down the pond but I have the better
structure
I gotta play F3 to support
and like all these pawns on the queen
side for black are a little bit weak
I have simple ideas of Bishop E3 and
Rook C1
I mean we might see like Knight D7 f8s
I could start with Bishop B5
not the craziest thing ever
because here I'm calculating here here
throwing the check and then go back
C6 is also playable
I'd rather keep the check open for later
The Rook C1 first
I can definitely work with this position
h4h5 has some idea
um
yeah that's actually a good move Bishop
C4
if I take
not seeing exactly what to do here
take it there and
maybe I'll play this
yeah the Knight would much rather be
here very reluctant I was reluctant to
allow the double pawns but if only comes
to C3 then D5 could be accessible
so I'm still down upon
now we both have ugly Pawn structure
on the queen side
looks like the pattern that you might
see on a cow
okay I could win back the pawn now takes
Doula Rook D2
go for it not sure about it though
take the thing
you still have an active Rook
and I see three probably coming
and I have this idea too perhaps
allow you'll see it
maybe it's okay
[Music]
um
no
foreign
tons
very long time
do I play for a win here
we should just be drawing
not quite though
okay I'll offer draw
okay
foreign
I somehow survived that
was a long game
oh man
I'll take the draw
I was uh I was probably I should be
losing around here the two two verse one
the black spawns got disconnected
playing sinkfield
probably not Rex
okay
and pre-move this
wow
the four pawns attack
yeah this is probably one of the
scariest things for
a cow to encounter
can I find night here
actually it looks playable
so I am happy to trade off
opal miners
there there
Bishop's a bit more active I could have
played Bishop G5 too
if I take
yeah this actually looks very reasonable
Castle next
I mean white still has more space but
this Pawn blocks the bishop I have good
control over G5
if white pushes and the King can get a
little bit more Airy
rookie eight ideas
and D4 can be a Target too
E4 is probably a good move
guess I'll start with
d6's
an issue
there there
hmm
yeah maybe it's still not good
can I Center Fork gnome
tick tick tick
okay let's try this
so if Knight takes Bishop I take back
with Queen C5 I think I suck
I have white Winds of Pawn
can I take here
G4 Bishop E6
looks so risky but
I don't see anything completely wrong
with it
so yeah we could trade Queens in kind of
a weird way
or not to mention G4 I have Queen E7 to
counter attacking the bishop
which is maybe even better for luck
okay I think I've survived the worst of
the opening and now
uh I should have a better Bishop too
like white slight squares are really
weak
D5 is kind of scary
and do I play
take
a default D5 makes a lot of sense
there there
thinking Queen E7
it looks crazy to like abandon these
things right I hit the bishop
we trade Bishops I take with check I
take back and
still looks fine for black
if the bishop moves I take and we trade
Bishop E6 comes with tempo
maybe even Bishop E4
I have to watch out for Bishop D6
let's start with this
a little rookie Yates
um yeah rookie one I play rookie eight
I think
I probably want to play F5 soon
foreign
establishes a strong Bishop post but I
can do the same
A2 is randomly hanging
six
you can play this and then take also
threatening mate
if I take I might be threatening A5
with uh
worth rank pin
this bishop it looks pretty but it's
wrong not really doing much
just a decoration
and this bishop is doing a bit more
it was a question how to bring my Queens
back to the king side
okay time's looking good
imagine if Rook D2 I get the queen to F3
Queen C4 is a move
should be okay though
I just have to watch out for the back
ring tricks and sacrifices
and that move I didn't see coming
I have this move threading this
oh no my Pawn
still threatening this
uh let's calculate takes
looks fine
yeah this bishop
it's utterly too strong
okay
another win with the cow let's go two
and a half out of four
so on the plus score
I'm still up reading for this tournament
too I started the tournament at 25.99
so yeah
gaining rating was such an opening
okay
oh playing down
here we go
is there sound sound
yeah let's start with A4 or A5
still put the Knight there
and yeah I can't develop without losing
the pawn so
E4 to start
I I did lose the tempo playing E3 E4 but
uh trying to make the most of it D5 is
probably a good move
I take
Bishop might take well
it's already a little bit questionable
Bishop C3
idea this and this
also pressuring E4
scared about 98
. maybe it's okay though
it's calculating 98 Bishop E2
is not happening
okay I think I've achieved a reasonable
position like black has a a small space
of damage with E5 Pawn
but nothing too
annoying
my Bishops will hopefully find some
happiness
yeah so I'm starting to win the piece
Bishop oh F5 is now a threat
and
that's a good move
I play this
and then F5 Bishop G5
or maybe this
yeah let's just offer some trades
interesting
yeah not a four may be coming
an id4 may be coming to
have to play very patiently here
take take
the hats of the passive
C6 not so expected
h
I'm really not sure what to do though
Queen C1
let's create the battery
hmm
try 94
Lock's really been holding off on
playing F5
and I should probably take that
92. a lot of the night maneuvering
so now offering the trade of Bishops
feeling okay here rookie two
[Music]
McQueen D2 first
how to do this
Queen D2 Rook C1 I guess
scared about the bishop coming here
that's so weakening
so F5 Queen C4 perhaps
so it takes I take on F7 first with
check
F takes Queen H4 Queen C4
hmm
turning this now
threading this and this
okay now now my queen side's solid
Black's Bishop isn't so happy threading
this
H4 also was a move there
has a nice Buffet of ponds
you gotta stay focused
I'm trying to apply the advice I was
saying earlier about converting winning
endings
It's gotta say super Focus to be aware
of opponent's counter play
speaking of counter play I don't think
that works
so I control B2
let's go
oh
three and a half out of five
I've far surpassed my own expectations
for this tournament
I was scared about going zero out of 11
so
I'm grateful to be here
cow is too strong
grazing on those pawns yeah
so who has three and a half
komsky has three and a half
well if I play commsky
uh
do I disrespect the famous Legend
moo
and Jeffrey also okay playing playing an
I am who is this
not sure who this is
okay
okay I'm happy to see G3
it's a lost confrontational opening
no White's trying to be confrontational
though
so maybe is this where I go for
I don't like H5 because H4 just kills my
fun
so maybe I go for E5
maybe like Castle
and then E5 eventually
take take
let's play Knight C8
it's not comfortable
E5 take
okay so my plan is of this I take
and at least I have the E5 Square for
the knights H6 is probably coming
in most of these lines
maybe it's playable that's really the
goal is to get a playable position
oh I'm losing a pawn though
take take take Bishop F6
how playable is this position
C6
maybe F6
that's really not pretty
Bishop D6
take take
regretting my life decisions here
I'll play this
can't spend so much time
maybe Queen okay let's start with this
if H6 I have G5
I want to play Queen Aiden
at least try and pressure the pawn
C6 restricts the Knight and the bishop
and this night's so bad though
Bishop B4
so I free that E7 Square for the night
and now the planet's Bishop F7
I don't think I can get away with
playing G5
okay I could play H6 here
maybe Knight B6
idea of this and this
this is terrifying
yeah I'm probably losing material
although 95 will come with counter play
Maybe
yeah so 95 immediately
I was expecting Knight takes but Rook
takes so it's also possible
Bishop E6
I think I just want to take him playing
out of seven
or maybe Knight of seven immediately
it's actually a useful Square for the
knights
control some key squares
take the Knight now probably
the fives may be coming
okay so setting up Queen C5 and rookie
eight
so Rook D7 I play Queen C5 and then Rook
E7
night guard's potential Pawn pushes
yeah F6 could be a problem
that's a great move
have this move
going after this
I also unleash the Rook so now I am
threatening to take Maybe
unlock the pawn
foreign
Knight H4
we trade then I'm hitting both Pawns
take this
check
feels like puzzle Rush King takes its
mate
King here it's Mage yeah queen of two is
coming regardless
go
how prevails oh a cow is becoming
stronger and stronger
got my first upset Victory with a cow
no mercy
except in the opening a little bit
because I played the cow
but no mercy in the middle game
Kamikaze yeah
yeah I just had to I think one thing
about the cow is
like it's a bad position but you have to
be grateful for what you have
like I I had bad pieces but
if you exercise gratitude towards them
then
sometimes that's the best way to make
the most of them
I'll be playing someone pretty good next
game
I don't want to play commsky though
I'm hoping I don't play anyone who like
will get offended but we'll see
it's the nature of playing Macau
lay has four and a half Hans has Hans
has four and a half
I play like Halligan's Hans komsky too
and draken
well there's a lot of big names with
four and a half
I wish there was Zen mode so I could
just hide
the identity of my opponent
oh man
is there are their games still going
oh okay woohoo
new game starting thank you rasikal
here we go
try and get the opening over with
quickly
yeah they've okay so I learned my lesson
from earlier I'm gonna start with H6
and then in this case the Knight
develops to C6
maybe start with B6 and then C6
yeah
the the modified cow because
opponent was too afraid of the normal
cowl and now this move
now can I go for E5
E5 take
let's go for E5
D5 Knight B8 okay now now I'm undoing
the cowl
oh man
um
Bishop G4 though
okay this counseling does not combine
well with H5 and now I'm ready to
bring my knight to a normal place
I don't mind taking
this first
keep the pressure against C4
and Bishop E5 also possible
I also don't mind the double Pawns
uh there's some night
annoying Knight B5
I have Knight C8
yeah maybe this is better to
reposition to E7
Nikki rasikal
they're they're I don't really wanna
start with this
keeping some tension
I love Queen B5
can treat this as a Gambit Maybe
Queen B5 Queen D7 is interesting
I should probably Castle
that four may be coming
yeah maybe I should take
and then Knight takes
the queen D7 here
now I probably have to do this
down a little bit of time but
positions still looks playable
I do queen H3 King G2 is expected
uh what to do I should probably play
Asics sooner rather than later
B5
B6 is interesting to
A5
I have F5
I'm giving the E4 Square though
maybe I got the D4 Square eventually
hmm
applying pressure
idea Queen f8
foreign
position
[Music]
this Rook wants to come in
I take
wow so take their
I can take and play Rook F4
Knight takes it's just this
foreign
it's heating up
ah I was looking for the stalemate trap
oh what to do
uh if I can sack both the Rooks
forcingly it would be stalemate
but unfortunately it takes the queen
just gets traded
ah good game what a good fight
and it still felt like I had chances
towards the end
I should play uh King G7 as a safer move
hold on to the C7 Pawn
what a game
okay four and a half out of
seven
still a plus score
oh playing rustamov okay
there we go
I played Roost time off so many times in
title Tuesday
never played the cow opening against him
though
attack upon
okay
discouraging each five
I think I just Castle here
yeah maybe we'll get some
like another King's Indian position like
if I play E4
now I guess cow is like most similar to
King's Indian
I had this structure a few times
I mean my knight really makes no sense
on B3 I'd love to justify it somehow but
it's difficult to do
this is going to be very similar to the
previous game
I have this move
and then Bishop G4
should be coming soon
forced to trade a light Square Bishops
yeah I don't think I can sack there
so let's take
and I could play Knight C4
Bishop E7
maybe I'll play this first
hmm
there's H3 as well
yeah maybe H3
the idea is to prevent h4h3 from Black
and now
and now I'll play this
but for this
so I'm imagining takes takes on my
knight can come to D5 perhaps
Knight should probably come back here
I do a lot of F5
well now you hear I could take and then
win H5
okay
I don't want to take and open the bishop
maybe it's playable taking an F4
it's interesting if Knight takes I have
this idea again
and this square is very valuable
are we going to see an exchange sack
I have Knights here
actually I'm kind of like the position
now
I'm getting a reasonable position
Against The Grandmaster with the cow
okay a five no
problem is still Knight T4 is looming
here
I gotta move quicker
yeah
Knight G4 is probably coming queen can
slide over
and I'm not getting forked
my king should probably be maybe on H1
I do apply pressure to E5
I'm not sure where this Rook wants to be
maybe E1 go for F4
or maybe I can reposition the knights as
well
hmm
idea to play Knight cd5
and bishop's still out of play
but it does restrict my idea with F4
maybe there's some ideas of Knight of
five eventually
I should probably shift back to the a
file or C file
wow
G5
King
so I'm turning that a six check
four would be insane
maybe I even
take take
and this
wasn't sure there my Queen's a bit stuck
between Queen is very stuck
just want to trade nights
neither one's a funny move
draw
go let's go
oh the cow is so powerful
118 moves okay
that's an item off the bucket list
ah
is it feeding a grand master
oh
I was uh I was such a crazy game
and it's a very difficult ending to
defend with a one second increment
oh man
getting my cardio in for today yeehaw
thank you smooth the brand
oh
yeah someone clipped it and send it to
Anna cranling
this position was so confusing too I was
so close to flagging like so many
occasions also it's break time much
needed a break
like it seems so close to Checkmate but
I had like less than four seconds here
and the King always seemed to have a
square like I wanted to check
like the bishop was Kian in preventing
checkmates
and then the king escapes and around
here I thought I was gonna lose
but then somehow I won the bishop but
even here like it's scary
did I miss a fork around I missed the
fork I had Knight C6
the pawn was more appetizing
that's such a weird imbalance like no
pawns on the board rook in two nights
versus rook and One Nights
how close were we to the 50 move rule
so 81
was the last capture
yeah my opponent would have had to
survive another 13 moves so he was
really close actually
if the game reached move 131 it would
have Auto claimed 50 move rule
okay
I've I've passed expectations I I think
I've tied my previous title Tuesday
score
from a week or two ago
ah yeah the 50 move rule
if you move 50 times the game ends in a
draw
it's never been applied though
okay trying to catch up to Fabiano
I'm only a point behind Magnus Carlsen
I have five and a half out of eights he
has six and a half out of eight
wow also a point behind Hikaru
let's go
okay oh playing commsky
oh it's email only okay
he's also streaming I wonder what his
reaction will be
oh man
okay maybe here's where I go for this H5
idea
but he'll play H5 himself
he's just playing a normal setup
yeah let's play
oh new idea Knight E4
do I dare Venture into new territory
maybe just Castle first
and then 94
he sees three first
akomski is one of the great positional
players of our time
Bishop F3
okay never mind
he's handling this very appropriately
let's play Knight E4 and see what
happens here
okay
I just hope he's not too insulted by my
opening choice
hmm I could play A3
there there
fore is also a move
yeah
how to do this
like the structure is not great look at
this move
maybe B3 coming
before the move
B4 doesn't work though
um
you really want to just leave a night
there and then recapture
is there any way to get away with that
like a five
take take of six
YOLO
leaving the night there we're gonna make
it fancy
takes takes I have a bunch of Pawns
uh this didn't really work at all
but we'll still try and make it work
so I'm only down the night for a pawn
I'm down a little bit of time to
take
take with a rook maybe you leave the
tension
um
so I have two pawns for the piece
he's taking initiative though
Queen D3 Maybe
foreign
ah I at least wanted to set up the
stalemate trick oh do they have chances
that game
oh it felt really close
after such a crazy opening zoo I was
probably the craziest
position now the opening I got at this
tournament
um to just sack a piece on D4 like that
it wasn't even like that bad
I got a decent amount of compensation
[Music]
that was a fun game though can't be too
upset
but did I did I have any chances
also what is komsky saying about the
game
Eric is having a lot of fun today
and I got just sold on time
Eric's having some fun today I guess
okay
not the worst uh worst quote ever
there we go okay playing down
let me try and finish strong
I am getting fuel a decent feel for the
opening
um
at least in terms of move order ideas
I know this E5 idea
I'll probably go for E5 again
[Music]
it's not easy for white to actually
punish despite following
opening principles
yeah do I play A5 I think A5 actually
makes some sense
preventing white from playing A5
and now
I'm just not sure maybe I'll yeah I'll
complete the cow
and now do I go for this
E5 idea maybe I'll just wait maybe C6
I'll take it slowly
C5 let's go back
D5 E5
I mean there's a funny line E5 F5
just closing everything down
holy cow
if white takes on passant then I I can
breathe a little bit
um yeah that's a good move probably
each five is maybe coming so
let's hunker down
maybe go for B6
I'd love to prepare G5 but I think
White's quicker to get in G4
and yeah I'm gonna have to
I mean I have Knight H6
I can also take and play Knight H6 which
is interesting
let's go for that
it seems ridiculous to like open the
king side in such a way but
I have the F5 Square now I have Bishop
H4
so the ideal to get this Knight to F5
which then would control G7
yeah I was calculating Queen H5 but I
think this defends everything
like covers all the potential Targets in
the position because Queen H5 hits this
and this
um but now I have Knight F5
and now the bishop can maneuver too
yeah this is turning from what was a
small baby baby calf into like a
hopefully soon to be Raging Bull
um Bishop G6
and it's still very tense
a lot of things happening here
Bishop takes her
actually not sure maybe bishop takes
offer the bishop trade
so I have B6
and B6 is double edged
I think I'll play it because it does
open up uh The Rook to the fan as well
and B3 could be as Harga D4 could be a
Target
yeah it's logical
so do I take
hmm
it feels wrong to take
maybe I should
um Bishop wasn't doing much
procure
okay so at least getting the Rooks on
purpose if here I I play here King G2
take and then win G4
so we might see Bishop F2 yeah
take
maybe Rook B4
so now with G4 I take on D4
Queen B8
it was Queen E8 as well
hmm
G5 let's go for this first just kind of
passive but
what else to do
okay now at least we're shifting Focus
foreign
idea
I'm just calculating this
so we're fighting Queen E4 now
uh
that's such a panic move
uh should not have traded Queens
that's not good
oh no my cow
I could move
man I had a good position to
uh what to do
yeah not enough
okay
uh it's a sad ending
uh I mean I could have taken a draw
it felt like a position to fight for
more
yeah can we have three for some reason I
didn't see coming
and then I completely freaked out
yeah it's hard to leave the queen on e4
because it seems like white wants to
take but
I guess in these situations and at least
I'm threatening E3
okay good game welcome back to Gary
I'm still up 15 no 16 points of rating
I started the tournament at 20 or no two
oh yeah 25.99
so we have one more game
if I
if I win I'll finish with like a par
score
all right here we go
E3 92
and I could pre-move like the whole cow
but
I have to watch out for Bishop G4
sometimes
um what's my theory Castle probably
uh
okay let's go for E4
because of D4 maybe I can get away with
A4
that okay we take back
so I'm hitting the never mind
this cow is getting kicked around
but okay maybe I can play like yeah
Knight F3 Bishop E3 it's somewhat normal
development
another five ideas later
every I guess Park wants to play 96.
so what about A4
because Asics I take and there's a pin
otherwise I'm trying to undermine the
structure
and chisel away a little bit
we might see Bishop D7 which
or that move okay let's take
A5 probably coming
or not
all right so
Knight of five
I feel like it's an opening success
I missed takes in Queen D7
uh I have Rook A6 though so maybe it's
not so bad
because the queen can't take because
it's tied down to defending the bishop
do I go full ham and just sack and
attack
it's an interesting concept
The Rook is actually very useful here
I want to activate the bishop too
so I could play
start with this
offering the trade so I don't mind if
the queen comes to E4
now
wow
take take
there's only G3
it's queen of three
there's also takes
we take some Queen G4
so threatening Rook F6
not sucking immediately but maybe
threatening this as well
there's also ideas like if the queen
defends I could take the bishop and then
play Bishop G5
perhaps
um
there's also Bishop E3 which oh there's
Bishop A3 as well
maybe three
how does black not lose
yeah cause the Queen's tied down to the
Fang in the bishop because I'm pinning
the pawn and Rook hits the bishop
if H5 at the very least I take the queen
take the Rook
at the very most media this move
this is looking quite good
so I'm having H5 take take take Rook A1
I'll win a seven
we do get that so
anything better
I am probably Queen G3 works but I like
the end game
if Rook takes I take the pawn
immediately
do have to watch out for Rook D2
that move
it's only way to defend
okay as long as I stay focused and don't
make any terrible moves
should be okay
a king wants to come to E2
where it comes to D3
[Music]
play Rook B3 first
up a lot of time here
um
look at this move
now there's almost some meeting idea
hmm
take their
H4
let's just take
that I forgot about
huh
that's not simple
I think I should just start pushing the
C Pawn
okay let's go
title Tuesday complete
final score six and a half
out of 11.
I finished with like kind of my average
title Tuesday score
so the cow opening
[Music]
didn't really slow me down too much
now I gained reading too so
maybe I have to rethink my opening
choices
going forward in the future
big thanks to Anna kramling
or the inspiration
and the meme opening
I'll probably put this whole thing on
YouTube so if you're watching in the
future on YouTube
let me know what sort of things you want
to see me do in future tidal Tuesdays
because maybe I'll I'll have different
themes to title Tuesday it's like maybe
I'll I'll do one where I play only
gambits
because it's fun to test out new things
against title players
and uh yeah I think there's like even
though this was like
going into it is mainly purely
entertainment I think there's
definitely some instructive takeaways as
well